[Musik]
also das ist aber die geistige aktivität
kurz gemacht
kurkuma und berichtet dass ich helfen
während der winterzeit
es war einfach gut dampfer in drei
minuten im wasser oder so und charly
hübner weil tomatis aller wirklich wie
ein netter haut und das klebt im
morgenmantel sache liegt da also auch
kein mitleid stopp wird
[Musik]
petrus feuer angezündet und kreuzkümmel
kurkuma dies ist die geschichte von
tamilen komatsu nahm der einst nichts
aus sri lanka hierher kam ganz gut heute
zeigt der ehemalige flüchtlinge leben
hungrigen schweizerinnen und schweizern
wie lustvolles essen gibt noch nie so
wichtig das kam mir energie geben kann
wenn das meine nahrung wenn diese bereit
also ich hoffe mit leidenschaft mit
freude als ein weder sagt thomas selber
mit freude das löschen und dann gibst du
wieder mit freude kosten und die
menschen wieder die freude
warum schmeckt das ja nicht nur das
kreuzkümmel und da ist man seit eben
auch wieder mitarbeiter werde ich sagen
du musst jetzt geht's gut motiviert
freude weil diese negative energie spürt
man sofort sogar gesund werden könne man
mit dem richtigen essen und den
passenden gewürzen dazu sagt kummer am
eigenen leib habe das erfahren können
seine kochkurse gespickt mit tipps und
weisheiten sind begehrt das aber führt
eine medikament wenn man außerdem wenn
du richtiger name von brücken oder
dritter stelle
die schnitte betriebe das noch seinen
missionarischen bitte so wird einmal pro
woche wobei er vorige woche zum tochter
jahr später erlebt mit die natur es was
der da um gaby kundschaftet und so mehr
geld meine sind in jeder woche zeigen
sie statt
seine kundschaft kommt aus der stadt und
vom land kummer des chef eines
europäischen restaurants mit
therapiezentrum mitten in der stadt denn
der mann der bei null hier anfing hat
sich buchstäblich hochgearbeitet
zum erfolg geführt hat ihm die eigene
tradition die uralte indische
heilmedizin aro.etr man kann sagen sie
hat ihn in mehrfacher hinsicht gerettet
aber dazu später führt lässt sich also
weder problemlos ein schweizer güte was
da hier aber jetzt im frühling sommer
aus er will diesen also petersilie und
dill westra ho
sie sind alles wunderbare bitterstoffe
gut wurde gegen hitze jeder mensch
bestehe aus drei fundamentalen elementen
so genannten doshas so will es die
algerische lehre unter anderem mit der
entsprechenden ernährung schaffe man es
die drei doshas im harmonischen
gleichgewicht zu behalten
ziel von all diese kuchen das was wir
kochen lassen sollte richtig verdauen
also dass verdaulich da braucht zum
beispiel habe diese gewesen
das ist nur dass keine chance wenn man
die gemüter kennt jeder koch
mich wundert nur wenig wie nichtraucher
wie schmeckt das noch zu 100 prozent
stimmen
das ganzheitliche fasziniert und dabei
will ich mir mit der ich eigentlich auf
aus
die drei doshas nach ayurveda heißen
vata pitta und kapha alle haben
bestimmte eigenschaften die drei doshas
bei jeder typ also wie brugge kv bürger
beteiligt war da aber eine echte schiff
eine sehr dominant das ist die qualität
wenn dieses beispiel die waren dominant
ich bin sehr beweglich aktive schlange
klar sensibler viel wenn peter dominant
ich bin in der macht führung
organisation und so vancouver struktur
methode sind einfach langsamer aber
methode aber alle drei jeder lust haben
und frage ist welche sich der kubus aus
wenn der partei ist er muss mit peter
walter name für dieses kupfer ist er
muss vergesse die kokoska ja den
samstagen die frei ist dann schlafe nie
so wenig wie meine große liebe
dann kann ich das
welche kraft auch immer ihn in seinem
leben vorangetrieben hat sie war stark
zumal kam 1983 als flüchtling in die
schweiz rechtswissenschaften hätte in
sri lanka studieren wollen
der bürgerkrieg machte all seine träume
zunichte in der schweiz sind der seine
frau emma cannon
in diesen schwierigen anfangsjahren
warteten hausberg gurten ihr rückzugsort
[Musik]
erst mal wenn ich hier in schiedsmann
ist sehr großer schock
die sprache nicht kenne ich bin 20 als
sie und die reaktion von der lügt und so
fast niemand krähe das ist nicht so
einfach aber ich bin da hier
da muss alles wie der vorläufer cumart
gehörte zu den ersten tamilen
flüchtlingen die in die schweiz kamen
bei der angst seien es gewesen angst vor
dem ausgeschafft werden und dem nicht
willkommen seien
[Musik]
thema kann nur schwer darüber sprechen
was ihr während des bürgerkrieges in sri
lanka alles widerfahren ist
ihre eltern wurden erschossen das
gymnasium hatte sie gerade beendet da
floh sie jemals hier marko marin
[Musik]
die so kalt sie als ich früher kam so
kann man doch nur ein paar jahre nach
der hochzeit kam der nächste
schicksalsschlag
unsere ruhe zu finden und dann kommen
und dann reden wir was machen wie leben
geht es weiter nach dem tod der ersten
tochter drei monate nach der geburt
bekamen koma und hemer später zwei
weitere kinder
tochter und sohn wie schnee
[Musik]
für hannah dean für die lanker alles
verloren hatte begann in der schweiz ein
neues familienleben sonntag bei der
familie satcom immer und kummer
massieren nach europäischer tradition
ihren 20 jährigen sohn widmen
öl kommt nach der geburt diesem dritten
tag kommt man nach hause
dank dann bist du warst nach montiert
konzerne aber sie stehen und sehe graf
alte verhindern aber das ist zum
beispiel bei uns früher die menschen
über 100 jahre gelebt im café mal erlebt
damit ist es ja ich frage sie haben
cisco massive ist ja das geld einen
logischen jahr dass das getroffen hat
nicht aber ja sogar mit massagen unter
der familie stellt zudem gibt es ein
problem das auch mit ihnen rede und ja
und das hat doch jeder im team
die ayurvedische kultur des programms
ist nach jahren des vergessens zurück
den familienalltag nicht immer zur
freude der kinder sowie studiert recht
tochter ally geht aufs gymnasium
es ist als würden die kinder von kummer
und hemer so ein leben leben wie es den
eltern damals in sri lanka entrissen
wurde
ja
ganz unten hat q mal in der schweiz
angefangen er wollte sich um jeden preis
integrieren
arbeit fand erst als blech puzzle in
einer bäckerei später gab es jobs in der
gastronomie heißt 2 aufs mal mit
arbeitspensen weit über 100 prozent die
eigene tradition seit fast vergessen uns
gelebt habe wie ein schweizer mit
bratwurst und rutschte
doch dieses leben setzte ihm zu dass
viele fleisch seife seinen körper nicht
gut gewesen sagt kummer heute allergien
hätten den geplagt und emotional sehr
unzufrieden gewesen
lange zeit in der schweiz aber wie
einmal im hinterkopf was machst du hier
nicht ist dass die hochsprung die juden
hat durch und wenn ich mal ist eine
wunderbare kultur nadig und so und warum
nicht von der man bisher aber dann habe
ich meine frau fragt machen wir wirklich
selbständigen und nichts kann sie bis an
das ist mir anfangen sie über auch
wieder diese verlorene spiel und so
können entwickler jemand kumar waffen
den schritt in die selbstständigkeit und
bildeten sich zu all weder therapeuten
aus zusätzlich zu den rettungs berater
so viel kraft sie da reinstecken würden
nicht alles kommen nur von ihnen das
mach ich sondern ich glaube dass jetzt
auch noch über meine eine kraft kids und
dann durch nie alles wohl du wohl fühlen
oder heilen unterwasser kräfte sind
relativ viele ihre kunden sind
mittlerweile stammkunden ja kummer sagt
sein leben habe sich mit der
rückbesinnung auf seine kultur ayurveda
komplett verändert körperlich und
geistig uns mit seinem geschäft hatte
den nerv der zeit getroffen
die stressgeplagte in unserer
gesellschaft finden entspannung mit
dieser ganzheitlichen medizin
dafür bisher aber extrem
regelmässig somit mehr und extremer
schweizer seit über einem jahr kommt der
rechtsanwalt peter da hinten zu cumarin
die behandlung das
geschäftsleitungsmitglied eines kmu kam
wegen einer thrombose und weil ihm die
ärztin sagte er sei leicht adipös seit
peter da hinten die athletischen
ernährungstipps von kummer befolgt hat
er zwölf kilogramm abgenommen
merkels zu massagen extrem gut das ist
das habe ich mir einfach generell für
meine befindlichkeit was er sehr guten
erfahrenen frank was wir im winter vor
kälte so dass eine frühe hinter felix
magath nein ich mache hier so tag unter
das fühle mich eben viel energischer
leisten
das ist mein blut fleißig verordnete
leistungen und weil das natürlich habe
mich also der körper so entstellt dass
das funktioniert ist es natürlich toll
in der notfallmedizin und der chirurgie
sei die schulmedizin unschlagbar sagt
kummer für alles andere aber habe er
weder viel zu bieten
wenn ich kann mich nicht selber spüren
was tut mir gut aber wie viel energie
hahne wie viel wie belastbar und dass
wenn ich kein mitspieler ddr müller
werden jetzt
die pidas shared von die anzieht ist
eigentlich erledigt und sie sollen
merken sondern genau aber etwas sagt
prävention mit das ja heute ein buch
werden muss man sofort sind es schon
besser
nein muss frage warum das mir ein buch
mehr darum dass mir nach kopfschmerzen
in die glut zeigt dass captain muss
wiederholt magst du regelmäßig etwas
nicht kommst du hier regelmäßig es gab
keinerlei sondern machen app ist für
euch regelmäßig
was vielen flüchtlingen der ersten
tamilen generation hier in der schweiz
nicht gelungen ist hat coma geschafft er
ist in dieser gesellschaft angekommen
[Musik]
hallo
willkommen danke dass sie mithelfen
ayurveda den menschen in der schweiz
näher zu bringen
humor ist eingeladen an den ersten
hochoffiziell von der indischen
botschaft organisierten bäder round
table in bern
tatsächlich wird ayurveda in der schweiz
schon praktiziert es ist aber zu wenig
bekannt es gibt noch viel zu tun im
zusammenhang denn so lassen wir möchten
mehr anerkennung für unser medizinsystem
es freut mich sehr dass heute auch
unsere kollegen des bundesamtes für
gesundheit
an diesem runden tisch mit dabei sind
behördenvertreter aus der schweiz und
indien und auch weder fachleute indien
hat sich zum ziel gesetzt dass die
eigene staatsmedizin ayurveda in der
schweiz von der grundversicherung
anerkannt wird
dazu braucht es zulassungen und
medizinische ausbildungslehrgänge kummer
kann damit wenig anfangen
heute hat es hier viele ärzte und
professoren die über medizin und die
zukunft sprechen
für mich ist die erste medizin das essen
wenn das essen gut ist und die verdauung
funktioniert dann ist alles gut
dann brauchen sie die medizin nicht
[Applaus]
ausgerechnet das essen sticht kommen an
diesem kongress ins auge
mit allen weder hatte diese verpflegung
in jeder hinsicht wenig zu tun
[Musik]
wieso sollte teil schwierig waren
ist es das vegetarische ganz
geschäftsmann von handelskammer gleich
dass bei der nächsten zusammenkunft
dieser art eher das essen liefern werde
in kummers restaurant schließt sich der
kreis dieser geschichte
mit seinem euro weder konzept hat es der
54 jährige geschafft und er dereinst als
migrant ganz unten anfing beschäftigt
nun selber ausländer
[Musik]
dennoch hat er noch nichts vor einem
jahr wohl für eine zweite weiter öffnen
seine frau hat ihm davon abgeraten erde
peter typ der immer mehr will hat den
rat seiner engsten vertrauten befolgt
vorläufig bleibt es also bei seinem
ursprungs betrieb also es ist
sehr viele kontakte eine gute leads und
so ist es für mich sehr wichtig also
wenn ich hier lebe ja ich kann aus stolz
und das ist auch wahr hatte wechseljahre
welch eine leistung es ist zeigt sich
nicht zuletzt daran dass keinem der
einstigen weggefährten von kuba aus der
ersten tamilen generation hier in der
schweiz auch nur annähernd eine solcher
tellerwäscher karriere geglückt ist
[Musik]